[Music]
guys most video games are not designed
with eSports in mind when your game
isn't balanced with the highest level of
competition in mind oversights are gonna
happen is there anything that you could
do to not get handed out there I'm sure
there is right so apparently this was
Jack's looking right and sometimes those
oversights produce the most broken and
busted stuff in all of video games and
no one knows that better guys than these
super smash brothers franchise which is
why we're counting down the top ten
broken characters in smash history
kicking off our list is a character that
Xero used to dominate the competition
early on in his smash 4 career that's
right it's the pre patched version of
smash 4s diddy kong as a relatively
small character with insanely early kill
confirms this little monkey was an
oppressive nightmare most players just
couldn't deal with this how it starts
that tell me is this how it starts see
we're working so hard finally be able to
get that grab oh yes he doesn't what an
amazing cup of this myth is feat grand
champion here super smash brothers for
Wii U smash ultimate might be new but
its current iteration of Picchu is
definitely broken enough to take the 9th
place spot on our list in ultimate Pichu
has access to a strong neutral game
flashy combos and to top it all off he's
so small that most characters have
trouble even hitting him that sounds
like top-tier to me seems like a great
yeah I think so there it is Oh the
secretary bit about it okay here we go
go big is that window tachyon ticket
coming in at number eight is Princess
Peach from smash ultimate now it might
be early days for this version of peach
but she's got everything she needs to be
a top tier great buttons good movement
and nutty projectiles and of course she
has insane combos
that look like they shouldn't even be
possible simply put peaches the
frontrunner for most broken character
and ultimate so far try to edge
coordinate their minds feel a lot of
syrup grabbing food snakes Bernie's
throwing it back at him or grabbing
every tactile that you know he's like
much braver in this game he has a four
of the states he's going he's recovering
hide oh we saw we saw in the umbrella
and the up there once it sold you here
with the pressure no now he's going out
he is going out Sora catching a PT by
the blast
our number seven spot goes to one of the
most broken characters in all of smash
yes it's none other than the ice
climbers brawls version of the iconic
duo is the most broken iteration thanks
in part to their incredible chain grab
which lets them kill you from zero in
one touch brawl ices are a terror in the
meta game and many hate watching their
boring grab heavy play style but yet
they're only the second most broken
character in that game that's just how
busted brawl can get a long way to go to
get this win but this is the beginning
of it could be oh wow
alright catches zero doing an
uncharitable shuttle if to get back on
stage and this is gonna make it one to
one if you complete
Sangram ever seen a Mennonite play
you'll know that they love to do that
shuttle loop onto the stage Elana like
Auto cancel it no Vinnie was looking
right for it he knows it that he does it
just as much taking the number six spot
on our list is one of the first broken
characters in competitive smash bros of
course we're talking about the original
pink puffball Kirby with enormous
disjointed hit boxes a Down air that
would make even Falco blush and multiple
jumps to recover it took players years
to figure out how to take this puff down
[Music]
just the merit at least for spacing
purposes oh wow yep here with a quick to
stack leaf
why that sledge canceled huh I'll tell
kills the 135 for our number five spot
we're going to take you to the world of
smash for doubles where cloud is king
now sure cloud was good in singles play
but this character it was a whole other
beast in doubles where the best players
in the world set aside their actual
means to run to of him cloud has
everything a doubles character could
ever want huge hitboxes great combo
support and insane kill power multiply
that by 2 and you have the best
character to ever dominate and smash
doubles oh my coming into the number 4
spot is the melee iteration of fox
mccloud fox's insane skill ceiling means
that in theory he's the best character
in the game what's this no items fox
only final destination
many of melees best gravitate towards
the character giving him an almost
cult-like fan base that foresees a
future at where fox is the only playable
character the year is 20xx everyone
plays fox had toss levels of perfection
he has an incredibly strong kit all of
which revolves around the effectiveness
of his shine and when played perfectly
there is no other character that can
match him and there's a lot of RNG like
that space matches Wow and there he goes
up to do that bit like 18 seconds in the
first doc is not looking dirty Oh even
dirtier oh nice job stop
Oh are we gonna get overrun smash Oh
beautiful stuff Pikachu stands atop the
smash 64 tier list which is why he comes
in at number 3 on our list just when he
thought recovering in smash 64 was
difficult enough Pikachu makes it almost
impossible with his incredible edge
guarding his own recovery is the best in
the game his hit boxes are huge and he's
got a guaranteed kill move with all
these tools at his disposal Pikachu is
simply better than the entire cast in
almost every way
oh wow I've never seen a runner-up spot
is reserved for bayonetta's smash debut
whether you're talking pre or post patch
Bayonetta is V number one character in
Smash 4
thanks to her incredible neutral game
disgusting combos and ability to pick up
a OneTouch kill from almost anywhere on
any legal stage Bayonetta was nerfed two
patches in a row and remained a single
best character in the game despite the
development team's best efforts after
all if you can do this you're playing a
broken character
[Applause]
there's only one character who deserves
the top spot on our list and that's
brawls Meta Knight the spherical
swordsman absolutely dominates brawls
meta game to the point where there was
talk of just banning him out right from
tournaments he wins the neutral recovers
from anywhere combos out of anything
kills with everything and wins every
single matchup in the game
Matt a knight does it all and the rest
of brawls tier list is dictated by which
characters can even get close to
standing toe-to-toe with him nice
neutral air underneath the platform and
that's that Opie stuff right there
that's subtle loop
yeah man I've broken them I mean we knew
that all right now MVPs playing pretty
broken hanging on man against one of the
best meta Knights versus snake in
history
oh man back hit down smash that will do
it nice way the weight there by the
narrow grab release oh that was dirty
mvd saying that was sing no smash
character has ever been this broken we
can only hope that Nintendo has learned
from the mistake that is Meta Knight
well guys that was our top 10 list for
this week I feel like this is the only
video where I could ever tell you to
smash that like button and not cringe
see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
you